[Música]
de uso de voz para performance vocal com
menos gasto de energia
vai fazer uma contração muscular
colocando com neuromuscular junto aí ó
esperar a tua resposta muscular cada um
tem a sua
coisa assim
agora o que vai fazer para me dizer com
jota
[Música]
tá bom e depois para sair vocês podem
sair para que que tem um segurança aí
que vai dar acesso ao Facebook dobrar à
direita no final do Corredor esquerda Já
estamos em Goiânia Tá bom
[Música]
[Aplausos]
quem é que você tá comendo aí é bonitão
é meus amigos e o dia hoje começou no
fumo não temos energia direito né só tá
que tá ligado porque tá tipo meia fase
eu falei para o menino que era meia fase
aqui um monte de gente entendeu que é
melhor fazer porque tem são três fases
de energia né aí só tá funcionando numa
fase de energia vai para cada fase que
tem que ir não sei como ela sabe disso
mas eu sei que cada fase é uma fase né E
aí é a vida é isso né que são fases
a gente vai ir no apartamento meu ali
tô um pouquinho mais para baixo aqui do
Eusébio e lá deve ter energia e internet
[Música]
mostrar para vocês um carro que eu
comprei quando eu assim que eu comecei a
ganhar dinheiro eu era doido por carro e
aí eu já tinha com muito carro aí
cheguei ter 8 carros de uma vez
[Música]
tirei minha música
ao banco ou chega ele tá morando aqui
agora é o Spider né
ar condicionado e tal vou mandar
reformar sonzão
é massa era pressão
então todos vocês aqui eu vou procurar
um por um viu
Gabi
Valentina Gabi
Gabriel todos da minha lista Ó Mateus
[Música]
passou um tempo viu eu tô sofrendo um
acidente com esse dedo aqui para mim
conseguir fazer o negócio do rádio
consigo mas se fosse
roupas estendidas
aqui é uma reserva então sempre vai
ficar esse Verde aqui direto
minha vida oi tudo bem mamãe
eu sou irmãozinho tá ali depois eu te
leve
como ela é linda
Ai que delicioso
[Música]
quartinhos
instrumento meu
as coisas de tocar de jogar tênis não
joga tênis mas sei lá
o que é cara
aqui tem um monte de Campo que
geralmente usa esse apartamento para
trazer meus amigos sei lá quando tem
show alguma coisa assim então papoca o
cama em todo lugar é ele nem decorado
nem nada do jeito que eu adquiri eu
fiquei com uma sacadinha que vai dar
para aquela outra ali tem uma redinha
como vocês podem ver meu irmão não está
bem
[Aplausos]
[Música]
é
eu acho
tamanho da piscina
[Música]
fingindo aqui tô mexendo na câmera mas
tô só distraindo vocês para lavar o boga
dá uma olhada de rotina né a vistoria
que é muito boa você tá sempre se
olhando sinalizando para o dinheiro
chegar a olhar para o seu negócio
dizendo assim eita não tinha isso cada
qual tem cuidado seus olhos falar em
órgão você já tiraram o tipo de leitor
de vocês você que tem mais de 16 anos
tira o título eleitor para poder votar
pro Brasil mudar também só se quiser
também Se vocês quiser ver a gasolina r$
eu vou lavar meu cabelo meu cabelo tá
crescendo pô pergunta se eu sinto
saudade do meu cabelo grande porque eu
tipo cabelo grande durante muito tempo
eu falo que eu nem lembro que eu tive
cabelo grande eu juro por Deus como eu
nem passo a mão achando que tem um
cabelo procurando um cabelo que eu não
tenho isso não acontece comigo a única
coisa que eu sinto falta é de ter o
cabelo para quando eu errar do shampoo
eu de condicionador eu poder botar
porque quando eu vou botar o shampoo o
condicionador é o momento que eu falo
[ __ ] eu não tenho mais aquele tanto
de cabelo e aí você tem que fazer uma
mágica é uma coisa praticamente
impossível que é Sugar tá entendendo mas
é isso não é feito para voltar é igual
tentar botar o esperma dentro da da rola
de novo voltar pro povo não tem como não
há caminho de volta aí eu sou obrigado
realmente a utilizar todo condicionador
movimentos no rumo do cabelo como eu
quero que fique eu quero que fique
maizena e massageando aqui onde já tá
começando o problema do homem né a
calvície isso me assusta porque eu tinha
cabelo até aqui tá entendendo eu tinha
cabelo muito e tá se acabando e eu gosto
de ver cabelo grande eu queria ter
sempre mas esse cabelo aqui já tá se
acabando todinho acabando e ficando
aquele fuá para frente o cabelo cacheado
atrás bonito e o forno na frente falei
não eu vou cortar e vou começar do zero
eu vou cuidar eu vou tratar da raiz
queria tanto meu cabelinho grande mas
assim sabe legal eu Tiraria 2 cm de rola
para ter muito cabelo tô nem aí ficar só
com nove Ô besteira rolê para reproduzir
gente mas ele já tá mais grandinho eu já
tô começando a fazer tipo penteados
entendeu Tipo um topetinho do do
Chimbinha
ó pra igreja ó mãe ó sou baterista da
igreja tá vendo ó minha mãe que pediu ó
meu Deus tenho saudade de ter cabelo
grande o povo perguntando se Demorou
tempo as velhas perguntando se é
promessa
[Música]
eu nasci cabelo enroladinho um monte de
cachinho
vem me molhar chuá chuá gostoso o
perfume mais
eu pedi para que vocês comentassem nos
vídeos anteriores do veda Ai que legal
tá fazendo Beco O que que vocês gostaram
de ver no vídeo O que que vocês queriam
ver vocês gostaram muito de ver a
produção de ver as pessoas que trabalha
comigo 24 horas por dia e a gente tá
indo para outra casa porque essa casa
aqui é casa pessoal mesmo minha só que a
produção fica em outro lugar e eu
resolvi junto com a produção para uma
outra casa alugada assim e aí lá eu vou
deixar vocês ficar mais um pouquinho com
o pessoal da produção para vocês
entenderem como é que é o trabalho deles
assim e que tem gente que tem
curiosidade né cara eu também tô
tentando entender porque que vocês
gostam O que que vocês acham engraçado
tudo que eu gostei já já vou pro show de
novo não vou ficar mostrando todo dia
ele puxou gente todo dia eu tô indo pro
show então fica imaginando vocês
assistir que mais tarde eu tenho um Show
que vai assistir você Nossa já tá
escurecendo E ele ainda tá aí menina vai
tomar banho até o chão entendeu então
hoje não vou mostrar o show vou encerrar
o vídeo por aqui mas amanhã no mesmo
horário vai ficar pelas madrugada mesmo
cara Espera aí pelas madrugada você que
é do corujão você que é do Jô Soares
você quer vídeo inteligente assiste
junto com o Serginho Groisman ele tá
assistindo esse horário clica em Gostei
quero que você comete aqui embaixo o que
que você achou interessante nesse vídeo
aqui foi bacana aquela hora que você
mostrou tal coisa gente que eu tô só
tentando tirar as medidas aqui para
poder fazer mais vídeo para vocês tá bom
Vou ficar aqui porque eu não gostei aí
esse é o vídeo três então tem o o dois e
um logicamente por isso que esse é o
três se não tem os dois primeiro esse
automaticamente vira o primeiro é assim
para ter o quarto preciso desse como o
terceiro enfim vamos ver se ainda tem
essa espinha até o sétimo tchau tchau